how did zeus come to rule a whole
universe of various divine pantheons how
advanced has human technology become
after all these crises and infinity wars
and where was sif for the last 10 years
these are the biggest unanswered
questions in thor love and thunder
thor's iconic weapon mjolnir has always
been something of a mystery was it ever
truly sentient how did it work beyond
the cop-out answer of magic whosoever
holds this hammer
if he be worthy shall possess the power
how could it actually gauge a wielder's
worthiness and does it psychically sense
thor's intentions when thrown similarly
everyone's favorite monosyllabic tree
person groot has always been a bit of an
enigma how can you regrow from a single
twig does that mean that his
consciousness is stored in every little
sliver of his wood if you cut him in
half do you end up with two groots what
even is groot
right well that one might be answered
already regardless the reason we bring
up these two mysteries together is that
as of infinity war the two sets of
questions now all apply to one item
stormbreaker the magic axe made from the
arm of groot stormbreaker has always
been a bit of an unknown in the mcu
given that it seems to have all the
powers of mjolnir without the benefit of
any of odin's spells and thor love and
thunder ramps up the weapon's power and
mysterious nature tenfold in the movie
the weapon demonstrates obvious
sentience and even a personality by
acting petulant toward thor when the god
of thunder attempts to summon his old
pal mjolnir there may be an answer one
subtly revealed early in the film when
thor plants stormbreaker in the dirt it
grows roots just like root was reborn
from a tiny burnt little twig it seems
stormbreaker may be attempting to regrow
itself from its handle as well
in the marvel comics the origin of all
black the necrosword the deadly weapon
wielded by gore the godbutcher is
thoroughly explained over the course of
multiple comic series the long history
of the necrosword its true nature as a
living symbiote and its creator the dark
god null have been fully fleshed out but
throughout the weapons mcu debut and
thor love and thunder the weapon is
never explained satisfactorily it is
evident from the fact that every god
seems aware of and afraid of the necro
sword that the weapon's history is long
in story but no portion of that story is
ever revealed when we first see the
sword it lays motionless next to the
body of its former wielder an unnamed
dead god beyond that we never learned
much about the sword aside from its
habit of slowly poisoning and maddening
its wielder as of a post-credits scene
in spider-man no way home at least the
venom symbiote does indeed exist in the
mcu proper so it's possible that a more
explicit connection to symbiotes will be
revealed in the future
okay yes the real world answer to the
question of sip's whereabouts since the
events of thor the dark world has an
easy enough answer the actor that
portrays sif jamie alexander was busy
filming her hit nbc crime drama series
blind spot but every hollywood
production is limited by availability
budget and an endless amount of other
constraints and those films especially
if they're in a connected universe like
the mcu need an in-canon explanation as
well lady siff was absent from the big
screen for nine years and according to
thor love and thunder the asgardian
warrior was out there somewhere fighting
something for some reason when we catch
up with sith via an interstellar
distress signal in thor love and thunder
she's in the midst of combat fighting
alongside some unnamed alien gods
against gore and losing badly however
that small bit of information is where
the statements end and the questions
begin where was sif all this time was
she not on asgard when it fell if not
why why didn't she return to new asgard
to help her people rebuild their
civilization who were the gods she
fought with and how did she know about
gore well in advance of thor and the
guardians of the galaxy
in the mcu for some reason it seems that
earth's gods are much more important to
the cosmos and its many goings on than
any other planets just like sif's
absence there is a simple real world
explanation for this earth bias the
people who make and watch the movies are
all from earth and while that certainly
explains why we watch movies about thor
instead of movies about some random god
from another random rock in space thor
love and thunder added a couple of
remarkable details to the mcu that make
earth's central status a bit more
baffling firstly omnipotence city the
meeting place of all the universes or at
least galaxies many pantheons is ruled
over by zeus of the earth-based greek
pantheon given that nasa estimates our
galaxy to contain over 100 billion
planets the odds that a god from earth
would be in charge are well about 1 in
100 billion secondly the film's second
half centers around gore's attempts to
reach the abstract cosmic entity known
as eternity and for some reason the
bifrost is the one key to getting there
for some reason earth's norse pantheon
and specifically its god of thunder
contains the sole means of access to
eternity surely one of the other 100
billion planets has a more suitable
pantheon and more suitable god for
getting to eternity
earth gods aren't the only beings whose
status in the cosmic order is in
question as of thor love and thunder its
regular human status is two
when daily life in new asgard is finally
revealed in greater detail we see that
it employs its own police force which is
equipped with armor and weapons that
look purposely half-human and half-ass
guardian that suggests an intermingling
of technology just as their flying tour
boats do given the fact that at least
some humans now have access to asgardian
technology in the story and since the
entire plot of black panther revolves
around the hyper-advanced country
finally sharing its technology with the
rest of the world as well we can only
assume that the humans of the mcu are
now centuries more advanced than we are
and there's another major asset that the
mcu humans have that we don't dr jane
foster when explaining her book and the
research behind it foster reveals that
she has essentially solved the physics
behind einstein rosenbridges aka
wormholes given that many physicists
believe that wormholes are based on laws
from both general relativity and quantum
mechanics foster's findings heavily
imply that she has at least partially
cracked the theory of everything slash
grand unifying theory even being
conservative foster's theoretical
advances paired with newly accessible
wakandan and asgardian tech means that
the humans of earth 616 have a bright
future close at hand in both the marvel
comics and the mcu the awesome night
infinite power of odin is named the odin
force it's one of the strongest and most
versatile energy sources in the universe
making odin more fearsome and formidable
than nearly any other god and even as
much as some cosmic entities like
galactus the odin force is what allows
odin to empower his spear gungner the
destroyer and even thor's trusty mjolnir
so it's clearly a force to be reckoned
with that's why it's absence from the
mcu after odin's death is not only
noticeable but raises the question wait
where did it go
in the comics the odin forces passed
down from king to king thor wielded the
bore force and then passed it to odin as
the odin force and he in turn passed it
to thor as the thor force but the mcu
never explains nor shows this and that
leads to two all-important questions
first did thor ever inherit that
tremendous power and if not might
instead the power have passed to
asgard's king valkyrie in the past the
line of kings has always been genetic as
well as political but ever since the end
of avengers end game when thor made
valkyrie king the two lines are separate
and so the mcu may very well have its
own thor force valkyrie force both or
neither
if there is one question that the marvel
movies of phase 4 have repeatedly raised
it is to what extent are humanity power
and destiny all related in spider-man no
way home we saw a human doctor strange
tear apart the fabric of the multiverse
in doctor strange in the multiverse of
madness we saw both strange and another
human the scarlet witch do the same on
an even larger scale
then in thor love and thunder we see
another human jane foster wield the
weapon of a god become a god herself and
fight toe to toe with gods as did her
antagonist gore and with the increasing
number of uber-powerful beings
populating the mcu that are not gods
like the watcher and the celestials the
question of what exactly a god is has
become more vaccine than ever a
particularly puzzling detail about the
mcu's divine beings is that their
continued existence and power don't seem
to be connected to the one thing you'd
expect to be guaranteed worship when a
desperate broken gore comes across his
own god and explains that all of his
worshippers are dead god admits that he
is happy to see them go he doesn't need
them nor does he care about their
existence
oh god she will die the gods of the mcu
are clearly not determined by worship or
by power otherwise the reality rewriting
scarlet witch would be one of their
greatest
so far we've covered the fact that mcu's
humans are stronger than ever both in
the growing number of superpowered
beings in their ranks and in the
hyper-advanced technology they either
have or will soon have we've also
covered the fact that the mcu's god
seemed to merely be a loose assortment
of powerful beings that aren't powerful
enough to be considered abstract
entities like eternity or the watcher
the obvious question then is what
exactly does the cosmic hierarchy of the
mcu look like two celestials attended
zeus's meeting of the gods even though
they aren't gods themselves every god
and their uncle seems to be aware of
eternity and so presumably also its twin
infinity do universal constants and
abstract beings cohabitate freely with
gods we know gods do with people so that
implies a surprisingly open and tolerant
universal community do the other
universal constants that we haven't met
like galactus and the phoenix act in a
similarly casual manner and we've met
two elders of the universe so far the
collector and the grand master so are
they gods abstract beans or something
else it's surprising that a universe so
jam-packed with near-omnipotent super
beans of varying backgrounds hasn't
destroyed itself yet
one of the biggest reveals in thor love
and thunder is at valhalla the fabled
resting place for deceased asgardian
gods is real upon her death foster is
welcomed there by heimdall who looks
happy healthy and serene so if heimdall
is in valhalla is odin there too what
about other fallen asgardian warriors
and if foster is welcomed there because
she proved herself worthy and wielded
mjolnir in defense of asgard then surely
everyone's favorite mjolnir wielder
captain america could end up there as
well perhaps more important than any of
these questions is the matter of
valhalla's accessibility for one thing
the very job definition of a valkyrie is
to freely travel between valhalla and
the other realms so can king valkyrie
just pop in to visit foster and heimdall
can she relay messages between them and
the living can she bring them back
alongside valhalla the mcu has already
confirmed the existence of two other
afterlifes the ancestral plane of the
wakandan people and the duat of the
egyptian people unless marvel plans to
make the exceedingly bold claim that
those three religions are the only three
that got it right then in general we now
know that afterlives exist and seemingly
all of them
the dead will drag you down into the
duet where you will remain forever
frozen in sand
as we mentioned steve rogers wielded
mjolnir so will he be given a choice
between valhalla and a christian heaven
tony stark saved half the sentient life
in the galaxy but died apparently as a
non-believer will he spend an eternity
of punishment in some version of hell
as tricky as it would be to stick the
landing on this existential conundrum an
answer from marvel would be a major
relief when it comes to the fate of some
fan favorite characters
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite movies are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]